[Music]
let's go to uh idaho falls idaho and
talk to andy what's up andy
uh
not awesome not awesome oh boy
well i'm hey i'm great i'm i'm grateful
that you
called i really mean that so what's up
okay
well my question is how do we honor our
13 year old daughter's wishes to not
take action against her molester
and also do what we feel is right
um
oh
boy
seek justice and i would say a
really important follow-up to that is
that my husband's anger is so
tremendous that um
i kind of fear
um
him taking action against this person on
his own
like he's fantasizing about
hurting this person and
i'm just stuck between i'm hooking a
hard place because my
i want to take care of my daughter but
i'm also
want to take care of my husband and
how are those how are those mutually
exclusive
[Applause]
well as far as like
she knows she knew that when she shared
this with her counselor that
it would be reported and at the time
there wasn't a name
and so
i think she was controlling that but
in the details of of what she did share
we figured out who it was
and having that information we're now
like
when uh the officer called us
there they said do you know who this
person is and the reality is
yeah we do like we're not gonna lie to
the officer right that's wrong and but
also we've promised our daughter we
wouldn't
we would honor her wishes and not do
anything so i feel like
yeah okay so
like
i'm gonna give it to you straight as an
arrow okay
um
i
i think i was i was talking to um
a buddy of mine who's a professor in a
med school teaches counseling classes
and her specialty is
um
is this
and i think it's 280
it's over 200 times
someone molests a child
before they're finally caught
200 plus times
and so i'm going to give you the
humanitarian answer is your 13 year old
does not get to drive this you have to
report it full stop i'm going to give
you the federal law standard you have to
report it not reporting it as a crime
you're an adult
okay
um and you don't have to oh no you do
have to press charges and move forward
you gotta get this this this ins this
devastating predator off the street
and right now it feels like the end of
time for your 13 year old and what she
needs is the stability that says we love
you we're going to walk alongside you
and this is the right thing right now
and so now you're playing a long game
you're playing a long game of healing
you're playing a long game of love and
connection you're playing a long game of
here's how to handle
um anger and frustration and rage
and you're playing a long game for her
relationship with you because you're
going to look up she's going to be 26
and the question is going be
um because there's gonna be a trail of
kids in this guy's wake
and
uh
the question will come back how could
you not have done anything
so this is a full stop conversation's
over we're going after a full tilt on
this deal
now when it comes to your husband you've
actually put me in an awkward position
now
because what like an ethical if i know
somebody's considering hurting somebody
else right then i have to make that call
and so what i would tell you is
your husband i simply don't buy
i don't because i've been raged out of
my mind and i still have a choice
now it's to a point where it becomes
premeditated so what he's going to
choose to do if he chooses to do
something stupid like go beat this guy
up or go shoot this guy or whatever
if he does something
he is intentionally choosing
to make his daughter's life
in more ash than it already is
because he's choosing to
you know what she's already lost her
autonomy and she's already lost um she's
already been heavily traumatized i'm
gonna take her dad away too
and there's a foolish childish choice
right
we've had this conversation that um
you know he's made a promise to me
that he won't do anything but he's just
he's
he just he's black i got it hey a total
dude i got a little girl i totally get
it
yeah
and there's a choice yeah absolutely you
know what i mean i'm happy to talk to
him too have him call a show um
but yes there's
don't
don't take her dad away too
sure
don't okay so the greatest gift you can
give her right now is to believe her
and here's here's where this is messy
okay here's where this is messy
i've been through a lot of
sexual assault investigations and what i
know is
taking away a victim's autonomy meaning
somebody came in and violated their them
their body their their
values they they took from them
they
they took power and control and a piece
of them
and then they come report that and then
i will go as the as the
as the administrator i go all right well
here's how i'm going to handle this and
they say no no no i go nope this is how
i'm doing it it's the right thing
i can be re-traumatizing
because now you're losing control yet
again of how this thing ends up
and what i would tell you is there's a
difference between working with adult
victims and children
and so we wouldn't let our children
drive a car we wouldn't let our children
aren't there emotionally they're not
there they're not going to make
great decisions there and so what we're
going to do the most loving caring thing
you're going to do is you're going to
say i'm going to get this person off the
street
and i'm gonna um seek justice for you in
the right way
um in an appropriate way in a legal way
and we're gonna love and honor you all
the way through
okay i fear we've handled this poorly
from the get-go because
she started freaking out because i know
it took a lot of courage to share this
like
we have five daughters this is like our
worst nightmare we don't do sleepovers
we
you know and so my husband feels i
failed at the one thing right i promise
it would never happen to my my sweet
girls but
i know it took a lot of courage for her
to share it and
and then immediately she wants to like
okay but i don't want to do anything i
just wanna and and she you know was was
like freaking out and unsettled and all
that stuff and so
you know we promised her that we would
not do anything and so like two parallel
realities are happening we're on the
narrative with her is
it's fine
we're doing what you asked giving you
power is what we're feeling and then
um the other reality is that we have
been talking with officers and we have
gotten the name there is something filed
and moving forward but then where it
would have to intersect and
make
liars out of us or whatever
with our daughter is is as if there is
like a forensic interview and the way
that that sounds sounds so traumatizing
i mean he doesn't want to do any of it
yeah
so
um
if i'm you in this situation
so let me let me let me back up a little
bit
your husband didn't fail
and you didn't fail
and your daughter didn't fail
you got preyed
on okay
then
um the first rattle out of the bag was
scary and disaster and we say things
like i won't say anything will you just
tell me what's going on i promise i
won't tell i need to know what's wrong
with you are you okay
and they tell you something that you
legally morally have to tell you
and now you found yourself in a pickle
right
the single so i'm what i'm telling you
is i'm giving you a pass on that first i
get that
something's not right tell me right and
now you found yourself in a mess
the single worst thing that can happen
moving forward is your daughter loses
trust in you
because then she's completely unanchored
she's already lost trust in humanity she
doesn't have those words yet but she has
um
she's lost control she's lost innocence
all those things
but she's got y'all
and so if i'm you
i'm calling a family meeting asap
with her and you and your husband and
maybe one or two other people that she
trusts not her own age but maybe another
um mentor a mentor or two that's a woman
or somebody that she trusts maybe from
church maybe from school whatever
maybe you do this in the school
counselor's office whoever she feels
comfortable with
and we're gonna say hey um
by law we have to go forward and say
something
and so this isn't a matter of
um us um not doing it it's a matter of
we're doing this and we're gonna honor
you at the same time and expect an
explosion and expect and i hate you and
you promised and you're lying to me and
whatever
and the only response that's gonna make
any sense is i love you and i love you
and i love you
okay
the longer this gap goes the more
explosive it's going to be the day the
police show up at school and she's got
to go to a forensic interview is saying
a sane interview and those are not
pleasant at all
well it's probably way too late for a
sane interview but like for a uh and
that's that's that's when you go to the
hospital and have an exam um but
uh for a forensic interview man yeah
those are really really tough real tough
and they're describing it like it's it's
really non-invasive and they can get a
lot of information from you know like
indirect questions and things like that
hey they're gifted
no i mean they're not gonna lie to you
um
but
it's just tough it's tough
and if you're there
it's tough to hear those um
your daughter asks those questions it's
a tough task anybody asks those
questions to think about that right
um
my guess is this can i ask you a hard
hard hard question it's totally
unrelated
sure um
if i'm only going to ask you i'm just
going to pau i'm just going to pause it
i'm going to put onto the world
if you have a house
where you get really mad
or you get really quiet
or dad gets really mad at things
those five girls have learned
how to
not quote unquote make mom mad
or make dad angry
if you do that dad's gonna get so mad or
if you say that mom's gonna do put that
away mom's gonna
right
and
ultimately that distills down to one
important thing they feel responsible
for the emotional regulation of the
adults in their life and they cannot
carry that
so
you
you run that down all the way she's
going to sit in that exam exam i mean
i'm sorry it's not a sane exam she's in
that forensic interview
and
you're going to be talking or she's
going to be talking and she's gonna look
over and see you clenched up or see you
weeping and she's gonna realize oh my
job is to make sure mom's okay
and that's not her job that's your job
is that fair
yeah it came out in counseling so she's
been she's had crippling anxiety
depression for a couple years obviously
this is really insightful with this
coming out
and part of you know the counselor did
say that you know she was fearful of
dad's reaction um
and it sounds like she should be
and it's his default emotion
he's got to stop
he has to stop
so when you say that you know
we can't lose trust with our daughter
that's exactly what are you saying that
it's not necessarily in this i'm sorry
we said we promise but we just can't
this is we have to do this
and
versus like the the
long game like you said like not showing
up for her and saying sorry just no no
you you have to let her know that you're
moving forward with this
she cannot find that out from a police
officer or a courtroom
she has to hear that from you guys
and it can i would open it be very
direct i told you that i would never
tell anybody
and
a
legally i made a statement that i was
wrong i'm not allowed to do this against
the law
and number two
i can't fathom another mom and dad who
loves their daughter as much as we love
you
experiencing this
and so as your mom and i wouldn't pawn
it all off on the legal stuff i would
say as your mom as your dad
this person has to go to jail
and so we told you we weren't going to
tell
we've had to change our mind
and i know this hurts you and i know
this uh makes you feel out of control
but we're doing what's right
that's how i would i would have that
conversation and then i would stop
i would i wouldn't just keep babbling i
would just say this is the reality that
we're facing now facts are our friends i
said this and i was wrong this is what's
happening now
and what she's going to feel is a out of
control and b
because somebody else is driving now
finally
and dad's got to get his freaking rage
under control because she's going to
drive those emotions further and further
and further into a black hole
because she's scared of what he's going
to do
and he's got to stop acting like a
toddler and act like a grown man
and dude i have a daughter i'm getting
raged out thinking about this okay
it's not a matter of not being angry and
not a matter of not being raged out
i'm saying you cannot grow young
children in a house where they feel like
there's a tiger that can go off at any
moment
and expect them to have any sort of
downstream emotional regulation in their
own life they're going to marry guys
like that
yeah i mean to be fair obviously like
he's not reached out like in the house
it's like these are moments with me
where he's safe and he can tell me how
he's feeling and stuff like that has
been very tender yeah
no no
i get that i'm not talking about this
one issue i'm saying overall like you
just told me that
no they they're worried about making
dead mad
you know what i mean
so um
and
i know y'all probably told her this but
please reiterate this over and over and
over again very common
that when the police get involved or the
counseling gets involved and mom and dad
get involved and there's all these
things a 13 year old can feel like
they've done something wrong
because those people usually only get
involved when somebody's in trouble
and it's important to reiterate over and
over and over again
i don't care if she
sent text messages i don't care if she
got in a somebody else's car and drove
to this person's house i don't care how
this thing happened what happened is not
her fault
full stop period
adults are supposed to be adult
and she needs to constantly be reminded
constantly be reminded that you love her
that you love her that you love her this
is not her fault
so i'll leave you with this
um on a very different situation but a
what i think is a
applicable
um
response
um there's some stuff that went on at
school
and my daughter got in trouble
she's six right so it's not like crazy
stuff
there's enough that my wife called me
during the day which is super super rare
um so i got home i thought about it all
the way home all the way home all the
way home i thought about it i thought
about it i thought about it
and i got home
and she came and meet me at the door
like she always does um and i said hey i
need you to come in my room and her body
immediately dropped
her shoulders dropped
and she knew oh i'm in trouble
and she came in my room and i shut the
door and i sat down on my bed and she
stood in front of me so we were eye
level i said did we have a hard day at
school today
and she looked at the floor and said
yeah daddy i did
and i put her face in my hands
i said i need you to hear me say this
every day i thank god that
he let me be your daddy
every day i thank god that of all the
daughters in the world i could have got
i got you
and i love you
and i gave her a hug
and she's been alive for six years
and the hug i got back
is the single greatest hug i think i've
ever received in my life
and then i let go and she didn't so i
started i i re-embraced and we just sat
there
and we sat there and we sat there
there's a time for accountability
there's a time for frustration it's time
for peace and there's a time for all the
things
but there's
never not a time for our kids not to
know i'm in your corner and i love you
and this little 13 year old girl needs
to know mom and dad are in control they
said some things out of the gate they
got to walk that back that's life things
happen and things change but when things
happen and things change we're gonna
look at tonight and we're gonna tell you
the truth and then we're gonna be about
protecting you and our community we're
gonna do hard things and this is not
your fault and we
thank god every day
that we get to be your mommy and daddy
i know this is tough tough season andy
and i'm so so sorry please please you
and your husband find somebody that you
can talk to about this please go get a
professional asap